tark olace Costa Rica's where we find
our next call of nature a call that
nearly turned into a crocodile dinner
bell
crocodile safari guide will Kia sabi
found internet stardom when a feeding
demonstration went wrong
scoring nearly half a million views
online I was feeling that big crocodile
was coming towards me they might win
like in quicksand but I was like one
step ahead you know I I knew from before
what the croc is what I tried to do the
day was like a normal day for us in day
another day in the office it wasn't too
close yeah right Wilkie well anyway he
escaped with his limbs intact but the
question is why the crocodile ate the
bait and not Wilkie crocodiles kids
pretty much go for any prey but it takes
a lot of energy to do that and they only
do it if they're very hungry this guide
understands these crocodiles and
crocodiles have an ability to remember
they can learn what's going on so it's
easier for it to know that this small
morsel will come every day than to use a
lot of energy when it's not particularly
hungry to try and attack the guide but
if the crocodile was hungry would it
have eaten Wilkie the crocodile was
hungry he would not have stood a chance
crocodiles can run 16 kilometers an hour
which is ten miles an hour and they have
about 70 sharp interlocking teeth so it
would have grabbed him in a second and
done what it does crocodiles are
dangerous like any any wild animals we
need to respect and I think that's the
key if you respect their territory their
habitat you respect their babies and all
that you can deal with it otherwise they
can be deadly to you